we're gonna kick it off with some hearts
of the stole heart stone heart hearts
are hardened hearts with hearts then I'm
going to talk about The Witcher
expansion hearts hearts of stone yes did
you think it was a joke that they called
it hearts of stone do you think that are
trying to go with heart stone or is this
is this taiidan so the hearts of stone
expansion is out now you've already
played it you you reviewed it for us
yeah
and ty I know you're excited to try it
out yes what why is it called hearts of
stone um there's a fee they say that
specific phrase a few times but there's
a few characters who kind of I think
it's kind of like a character study of
Geralt how he's kind of incapable of
loving people although you can love
people in this expansion I loved a lot
of people point of The Witcher is is
loving people yes you love people and I
loved a whole house of women once in The
Witcher 3 and and yes those are very one
of the villains there's a kind of a
couple of villains and they are both
just heartless I guess that's how it
ties in I would imagine because one of
the person people who says that phrase
to Geralt is ends up being kind of a
jerk so so you get to learn a little bit
more about Geraldton and it's a very
story focused expansion this is this
isn't something that adds a lot of new
gameplay elements very few you do get
ruined crafting which is just another
way to kind of affect how you signs so
exci now the one that stuns people or
turns them against other allies you can
kind of chain it if you kill them in a
certain time it'll chain the next person
but yeah those things are all kind of
miniscule compared to the story and
everything here you'll see you know
hopefully spoiler free gameplay right
now but you do a lot of things that kind
of cater to what made the witcher 3 main
game so good it was just each quest had
a lot of substance and how they told
their stories and the self contain you
know little asides that played into the
main story like quests really well and
the characters are awesome pretty much
everyone you meet you meet Shawnee
here's a that was all geared Vonn
everich this is the there's Shawnee
right here in the scene as well as a
gaunt arrow Tim who he's one of the
people you have no idea the whole time
what their motivation he doesn't look
evil
little he doesn't most of the time until
he does this your face he marks you like
because you're kind of his Lackey for
there's a probably a different term I
could have used but yeah for so a lot of
times you're carrying out quest for him
whether you want to or not there's a go
unto girls history about why he likes
redheads so much mmm no I don't think so
not that I remember he his workout
routine yeah cuz talks about his like
CrossFit training yeah he does he does
CrossFit he drinks a pro complex when
he's working out
five-star so I know Shaunie is one of
the characters that you're most
interested in learning in and seeing
more time yeah I mean I I've always
appreciated The Witcher just because of
its story it's it's weird because I've
now hit that Shriver I've been playing
so much Metal Gear for so long for like
over 60 hours where I'm I'm now really I
now yearn for a good story
I want a actual good story in a game
because the the metal gears is just
complete [ __ ] sorry but the gameplay
is amazing some people might argue with
you they're dumb they're wrong
that story's horrible but regardless The
Witcher has that's what grabbed me
always was the story and you can see
that throughout the entire game the
actual main game not just even the DLC
is that they borrow from so much like
fairytales literature certain tropes
obviously they're gonna like you know
touch upon but it's nothing like but
they always kind of have their own spin
on it you know it's always something
unique and they're side quests are so
good and like they're interesting and
the stories behind them are interesting
and yeah you can approach all these
characters different ways but one thing
that I've always loved about the witch
and I mired about it is that it does
make you care about the people and the
characters the gameplay is good it's not
like revolutionary but obviously it's
the story that actually grabs me and so
I I it's is this a continuation of his
story or is it like before the events of
Wild Hunt it's kind of just during the
Wild Hunt you go as it's recommended
level 30 but you pretty much will just
get a prompt for to go to this bulletin
board in the town and I'm gonna meet
someone there that's like I'll come by
old eared Von Erichs Manor and he'll get
tell you more and that kind of sets off
a few different quest lines that you go
through with a main one and a few side
ones because the game is so story
focused it's hard to talk about it and I
think not spoil things but you did give
the game overall 1-9 yeah
it's all it's really good I mean it the
pacing is excellent it's also liked I
had mentioned it really like The Witcher
3 in general plays on like you know
fantasy tropes and whatnot this one
really pushes that but each of them kind
is very subversive in the way they tell
them you know there's the prince and the
Frog which I guarantee you that fairy
tale has never been told the way that
the CD Projekt RED does it here there's
this character who's very very
terrifying it looks like something from
like Pan's Labyrinth I like that you cut
away from this right before he reveals
his face yeah that's gross God yeah but
like within the first two hours you're
fighting three different bosses like
mini bosses and they're all unique in
their own way but you go to a wedding
and it sounds boring and there were a
few you know I kind of had a few
complaints with these minigames that
you're kind of forced into but they
don't last that long and they're very
minor in the grand scheme of things but
it's just very funny the wedding plays
out like a sitcom in a fantasy world
then you do a heist feels like Grand
Theft Auto if you know or Ocean's eleven
if it was in you know middle-earth or
something or the northern kingdoms I
guess to be more specific so there's a
lot of kind of a lot of different things
you can do kind of coalesce in an
awesome way yeah you mentioned in your
review that maybe the minigames and the
detective sections didn't meld quite as
well yeah the detective sections I
always felt like they were forced in the
main game I guess it plays into girl
like the witcher's abscissa characters
yeah but these ones were almost would
like one exception I think there were
eight of them that I went through and
each one was just followed this blood
trail to 20 feet away and find this
thing that I could have just seen with
my eyes as a human without you know
those cat eyes there's a care to the
college host peepers and I assume that's
because your cat eyes but maybe it's
just a Northern Kingdom slang for
something meaner and so this is kind of
a precursor to more which are content
we're going to be getting an early 2016
the blood and wine expansion and that's
going to expand the story out even more
this was about ten hours I think in the
blood and wine expansion is going to
continue that by even 20 hours what kind
of additional things do you want to see
in the game um I just like to see more
these quests that fit it was hearts of
stone fit pretty seamlessly into the
main game I'd like to see that continue
but at the same time
I'd also would not mind as you know by
the time blood and wine comes out you
said it's quarter one I know just first
half first now it's first half of 2016
used to make you one big a little later
sometime in 2016 before summer so with
almost a year removed from The Witcher 3
full release I would not mind seeing
them do kind of either a prequel or you
know continuation of the main story
because I think this the during the fall
release schedule this was a good time
for someone to say hey if you want to
pay $10 for quest is going to fit into
the game go for it but later on down the
road we're going to give you something
that's going to reward you for having
beat the game or kind of knowing these
characters you maybe will go back to see
what was going on before this I would
not mind that at all and I think that
would work and time for someone who does
I think in your job you don't get to
play as games as often as known as a lot
of us do but this is something to them
yeah it's really cool doing you you
played a lot of The Witcher 3 yeah what
does that keeps you going along and do
you think that just in more stories that
enough to pull you into yeah I mean I I
just think it's about taking a break
right I mean I think the beautiful thing
about this expansion and then the next
one is that they're their time too far
apart enough for me to kind of want to
go back into that world and actually see
what Geralt is up to now evening and I'd
like to see more I love the politics
behind this game I love that that the
story of this game is not so much about
what is happening with with like series
dad and the Emperor and and and novigrad
it's more about or Roche and that whole
thing and tameria it's more about what
girl wants right but all these political
themes and and snowballs are kind of
like in place you know like about that
like explode at some point so you have
all this stuff kind of going on around
you but it's not really it doesn't mean
much to you as your character you just
kind of observe it I'd like to see what
happens now like depending on what
actions happened the end of your game
like for example I'm gonna spoil
everything for something now so you just
turn this off you don't listen to it but
in my game Siri takes over as Empress
right so I would love to see what
happens after that like like how is she
as an emperor you know or an empress
like this yeah did she rule more fairly
than her father you know her father
killed a bunch of people didn't to my
game and kind of pissed some people off
but she takes over how does her now
political leanings affect the story
then the world around you you know and
also like there's so many awesome
syquest in that game like there I
remember this there's this one where you
have no idea of what you're doing is
like good or bad but like some lays like
hey it's it's another spoiler I'm
warning you now turn this off uh it's
like throw this baby in the oven just
[ __ ] trust me you know you're like
okay and you're like split seconds to
react right but those stories are so
engaging they all kind of like come
together to like really help something
so and like help progress a story you
and your character and it's just it's
it's really really good storytelling and
so I'd love to see more of that last
question if you're still here and you
did not turn off even though ty kept
telling you to turn away I'm gonna spoil
[ __ ] what what is the most surprising
thing that you can say without spoiling
something that you think people are
going to be really surprised to seen in
the gamer that wasn't really kind of
shocking or big moment for you um there
was a brief glimpse of it during the
gameplay but I don't think if you don't
know what's going on it won't make sense
there's a part where you are not in well
obviously the whole gamer not in the
real world but you're not in the game's
world anymore you go to this kind of
metaphysical dimension and was crazy but
it worked so well and somehow they made
it work and I think that was my favorite
part it was kinda was just this
alternate universe that was gorgeous but
also has scariest [ __ ] it was there you
saw that guy about the lip stood that
part was scary
yeah just like fighting him and seeing
him was bad there's always a lot of
those like weird creepy moments in this
game like that little really what are
they called by the botulin the box link
oh the time I saw that it was awful but
that's not in the new one so yeah but
there's always like something new like
that and weird oh I would also love to
hear more I always the the elven sage
that helps ciri throughout the entire
story again spoiler you have five
seconds turn this off turn this off okay
anyway that elven sage apparently you
know I like to know about his world
where he comes from
he helped kind of like one of the Wild
Hunt guys was like a student it'd be
kind of cool to kind of explore that
yeah there's a lot cool interpersonal
ties yeah and that was a surprisingly a
top that we kept on track and did not go
into inappropriate things which I
thought might have been more likely
hearts of stone is out now you should go
check it out and as soon as you get the
chance to play it we'd love to hear what
you think
how are you enjoying this extension of
The Witcher 3